how about brian vegan dining day
okay let's be honest vegan dining hour
just give me one hour that's
that's all i can do it's all right all
right outside right
look at the sunset gorgeous sunset again
nine tower cams to show you this one i
chose because
a beautiful sunset at this hour as we
look at the las vegas strip and of
course the spring mountains
the current conditions outside 58
degrees your winds only three now they
will pick up more than that tomorrow
as we will elevate our winds just a
little bit tomorrow the stronger
winds come though saturday and certainly
next week centennial hills 58 right now
summerlin 54
56 aliante 61 downtown we're in the 60s
look at this mid 60s
for sunrise manor and the strip it's
very comfortable out there 63 in
green valley henderson 56 for you rhodes
ranch and mountains edge
57 seven hills and also uh anthem
in the high 50s at this hour so warmer
today than yesterday certainly 61 in
mesquite
65 for boulder city 64 and 66
in death valley and numbers will get
warmer milder tomorrow
and the next day and beyond also on
saturday too here's our doppler network
now they're all sweeping around
not picking up any rain but we are
seeing those clouds clear and that will
be
also around this evening we do have
these clouds that will be moving in the
pacific northwest but we still have this
big ridge here that will be
in place uh for these next few days and
that allow the temperatures
here to now warm up but also in southern
california well they'll be flirting with
records too as far as those temperatures
go but we also have red flag warnings
there too
so here's your wind profile for tomorrow
we will get those breezy winds midday
and also the afternoon and then they'll
decrease tomorrow evening 43 degrees
overnight mostly clear
and chilly overnight your high for
tomorrow get this all right 68 degrees
closer to
70 with those mild breezes in the
forecast
for tomorrow all under partly sunny to
mostly sunny skies extended forecast
shows
breezy winds saturday too will come
close to the record that day but not
going to reach it or beat it
and then next week there's the cooler
conditions and also
the windy weather on tuesday that's your
most accurate forecast denise